nous sommes nous avons en fait un groupe ici en
france euh appelé les républicains en france
qui soutiennent donald trump
euh ce qui est en jeu dans cette élection
c'est l'élection la plus critique de
notre vie
[musique]
c'est un conservateur la plupart de ma vie d'adulte
mais  je vous dis qu'après avoir vécu en france
vous avez même tendance à aller
un peu plus à droite mais il y a beaucoup de
programmes socialistes euh ici en france vous savez c'est
tellement dépendant de l'état des
impôts si élevés qu'on commence à voir
ce que c'est vraiment
et c'est  des niveaux très très frustrants
à propos de vous savez
travailler et voir une grande partie de l'argent de nos impôts
euh
supprimé je réduis les impôts et il veut
augmenter les impôts de tout le monde et il veut
mettre de nouvelles réglementations sur tout ce
qu'il tuera s'il entre, vous
aurez un  une dépression comme
vous n'en avez jamais vue,
mais nous sommes aussi un peu dérangés par sa
propre
[musique]
ces citoyens qui
suivent chaque fois qu'ils entendent parler de
quelqu'un de l'État disent quelque chose
qu'ils traitent comme un, euh, ils le traitent
en tant que grand prêtre
et ils disent d'accord, nous devons tous porter ces
masques idiots comme
nous l'avons été en ce moment
to to to to the
to the tomb mais que
disaient les américains en
1776 nous ne sommes pas nous ne sommes pas des enfants nous sommes des
adultes
et le parti républicain surtout maintenant depuis
quatre ans
est le parti des adultes et non des
enfants  vous savez qui ont besoin d'être choyés
par leurs um par leurs nounous tout le
temps
nous ne voulons pas de nounous nous avons beaucoup d'
ennemis je pense que l'union européenne est un ennemi
ce qu'ils nous font dans le commerce
maintenant vous ne penseriez pas  de l'
union européenne mais ils sont un ennemi y a-t-il des
tensions entre les
états-unis et l'europe bien sûr
parce que
c'est comme l'amour dur dans une famille vous
savez qu'il leur tient tête des
organisations mondialistes géantes comme les
nations unies
comme le monde  organisation de la santé
union européenne et décider du nombre
d'immigrants autorisés à entrer
dans votre pays
vous savez il y a beaucoup de français qui
sont contre cela vous savez mais ils
ont du mal à s'exprimer je
leur ai dit aujourd'hui l'
ue l'union européenne vaut mieux  soyez très
prudent
car l'immigration envahit l'
europe et ils feraient mieux d'être très très
prudents
et j'ai dit que l'afflux fort et clair est
un peu élevé
[Musique]
et c'est un peu cruel de faire
venir des gens ici alors qu'ils n'en ont pas vraiment
les moyens de
les accueillir de manière civilisée
je vis dans une ville social-socialiste de la
banlieue parisienne
où ils ont transformé ce qui était un hôtel
en
lieu de réfugiés et les gens vivent dans des
conditions très misérables il y a l'un des
présidents les plus racistes que nous ayons  avait dans l'
histoire moderne,
il verse de l'huile sur chaque
feu raciste, chacun de ceux qu'il a commencé
sa campagne en descendant l'
escalator en disant qu'il se débarrasse de
ces
violeurs mexicains, il a interdit les musulmans
parce qu'ils sont musulmans et bien Trump a
prouvé qu'il est tout sauf un raciste
et je sais que c'est ce dont la gauche
aime accuser les gens
dès que vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur les politiques, mais
il a tout fait pour prouver qu'il est
tout sauf un raciste
entre les zones d'opportunité de réforme des prisons, un taux d'
emploi élevé pour la population noire
aux États-Unis.
le vote ici est le
caractère de ce pays
décence honneur respect traiter les gens
avec dignité en
veillant à ce que tout le monde ait une
chance égale et je vais m'assurer que vous
obtenez ce que
vous n'avez pas obtenu au cours des
quatre dernières années nous allons bien  avec lui
venant de derrière tu sais et donnant
cette impression qu'il est
derrière ça va être un choc pour le monde le
3 novembre